um yeah hi and welcome nice to see uh so
many people here really excited to speak
here
um we will present a present a session a
practical session on learning about
heterogeneous graphs with python
geometric or Pi G
um and I myself am Matthias Phi I'm from
Dortmund Germany and we'll be speaking
here with Ramona which is my colleague
at Kumo Ai and I will go through
gnns and why you should be interested in
them and why are they the best choice
for machine learning on graphs and then
I will also introduce Pai Chi like best
practices challenges and so on and then
we'll hand off over to Ramona which will
go through the Practical session which
you can also follow on your on your own
devices
um and so
just as a quick introduction why we
should care about gnns in particular and
so if we look at the Modern deep
learning toolbox and we see that this
toolbox is heavily designed for simple
sequences and grids and so we
traditionally use like convolutional
neural networks to process images or
Transformers and we also use recurrent
neural networks and so on to process
sequences
but not every problem can be framed as
such because like not every input we can
think of can be represented as a grid or
a simple sequence and so the main
motivation here or the main question we
ask is how can we develop neural
networks that are much more broadly
applicable
and so if we look at the real world then
we see that nearly everything can be
represented as a graph and a graph
usually consists of a set of nodes that
are our entities in our world and then
the edges between these nodes denote how
these two entities relate to each other
and so for example a social network is a
is a prominent example of a graph where
we have users as entities and then we
have edgers connecting these users and
so on other examples are for example
traffic networks communication networks
and so on and we can also see that on on
all different kinds of scale we can use
graphs so we can really use uh use
graphs for describing high level
Concepts such as social networks but we
can also think about describing
molecules as a graph and and use neural
networks to process them
and so the main problem we have here is
that graph data is different from grids
and text and so in particular they can
have like arbitrary sizes which means
like the number of nodes for example is
may be different there's some some
complex topological structure beneath
them
um
secondly we usually have no fixed node
ordering or reference points so if you
think about like a CNN then it is clear
that if we if we apply a CNN then we can
directly reference like the top right
pixel to the current pixel but there's
no no such different definition in a
graph and so we usually speak about no
fixed node ordering here and then graphs
are often Dynamic which is in in
contrast again to to images or text
because I I've rarely you seen a graph
that is not changing over time
and lastly we are speaking about in in
Practical cases we are mostly interested
in in heterogeneous graphs and that
means that we have different types of
nodes and different types of edges and
to these different node types we have
different node and Edge features
attached to them which makes them kind
of a multimodal problem to tackle
so if we look at the traditional machine
learning Pipeline on graphs we are
questioning ourselves like how can we
capture this network structure as input
feature or how can we combine this
network structure that we processed and
combine them with attributes such as
nodes and Edge features
um and especially how can we use that to
perform tasks at different levels of the
graph such as the task at the level of
notes edges or graphs and then we see
that if we put that into machine
learning pipeline then we actually use
many many different tools and Frameworks
to process them so for example we use
panderer so numpy for feature
engineering we do some data splitting
and so on with sklearn and then we
process that all into like a tabular
data layout and then use actually boost
or neural networks MLPs on top of them
to apply them
and so
there are two prominent approaches in
doing that this way and the one I
mentioned earlier is known as some kind
of pre-processing node features and the
goal here is that we kind of capture
Network structure uh as input features
and so one way to specify like how
important the node is in a graph maybe
the node degree which simply describes
the the number of neighbors attached to
that node we can think about more
complex input features such as node
centrality measures clustering
coefficients and so on but the ultimate
drawback here is that
uh all these features are super
arbitrary so we do not really know in
advance what features we are really
interested in in our Network structure
it is also expensive to compute
especially some kind of clustering
coefficients and so on and ultimately we
are losing signal because we just uh the
the final machine learning model has
just input to the features we
pre-processed in advance but not has no
access to the raw graph
the second traditional machine learning
model which is kind of which was kind of
popular like uh three or four years ago
uh it's known that the shallow embedding
model and that references the lines of
work of deep walk or no to vac and those
are all like random walk based which
means
um they're built on the intuition that
we embed each note in an embedding space
based on whether Whenever two nodes are
nearby in the graph we want their
embeddings to be in nearby in the
embedding space and if we have two nodes
that are like far far away in the graph
we want also their embeddings far away
in the embedding space and so we we
usually train that in like word to vac
or contrastive learning scenario where
we sample random walks and then push all
the embeddings of this random walk of
the notes uh inside this random walk
together and then assemble negatives and
we push them away and ultimately that
works well for some kind of Link
prediction test but it has drawbacks as
well it's in particular it is super hard
to scale because we basically learn a
shallower embedding Matrix for all all
nodes in our graphs and if we think of
really big grounds that is like a giant
embedding Matrix we need to learn here
um we are using like an unsupervised
learning loss which does not necessarily
align with the task we are interested in
and it is transdactive by nature that
means whenever a new node comes in or we
want to apply that model in a different
graph then we're basically stuck
and so graph neural networks got really
prominent in that sense because it does
not have all these limitations
and in the essence graph neural networks
are
best described as some form of neural
message passing scheme in the sense that
nodes send messages to the neighbors
they got aggregated
and these messages get learned and
trained and so I personally see them as
some kind of generalization of any
neural network architecture and I find
this kind of cool because what we have
here is basically that we're using this
input graph and use that as our
computation graph inside our neural
networks and so that's actually a new
paradigm of how we define neural
networks in the sense that we no longer
have static computation graphs in our
neural networks but we actually input
the computation graph into the neural
network and so that naturally allows us
to use graph neural networks as a super
high level concept to go for example
from cnns to gnns in the sense that we
are moving away from discrete
neighborhood sizes and allow like
Dynamic neighbors arbitrarily positioned
in space and we can also see them as
some form of generalization of
Transformers which is in the concept of
gnns uh just a neural network that
operates on a fully connected graph and
whichever node is connected to every
other and then we're using attention to
pass messages between these nodes
and so how how does that work in in in
the formular way and so granular
networks can be described as a way to
update node representations by
repeatedly transforming and aggregating
informations of direct neighbors so
we're having this function here called f
and that is parameterized so it can be
learned and it takes in the input
features of the node we are interested
in and all the input features of this
direct neighbor and then it uses this
information to compute a new feature
vector or a new embedding for this node
we are interested in and so that scheme
below here shows it quite nicely we we
have the central node here which is
marked as a green note the blue nodes
send their messages to this green node
they get aggregated and that information
is then used to compute a new
representation for the next layer
um
and so they have some ultimate graph
neural networks of some some some nice
property and strengths for example all
these GNN layers can be trained because
all of them are differentiable and so
you could think of them as having some
kind of sub-neural networks that
describe how we aggregate information in
each different layer and so if we're
looking at the graph here on the left
and we want to compute the
representation for this target node then
this will amount to the computation
graph shown on the right where all these
little gray boxes denote how we
aggregate information at all different
stages
importantly each node uses the same set
of parameters or these parameters are
shared which makes gnns inductive by
Nature so we have no problems using them
and applying them on New nodes or graphs
and then G and N layers as in cnns and
other architectures can be naturally
stacked and that helps us to reach
long-range information from nodes far
away from the target node
um gnns in in the essence just are
responsible for giving us a note
representation but we can use this
representation then for a given
Downstream task and the most popular
tasks are known as node classification
graph classification and Link prediction
so in the node classification we want to
predict the class of a given node so we
have a neural network that gets the
graph as input and a specific node V we
are interested in making a prediction
for and so we can directly use the layer
of the representation produced by the
GNN which is here age in in the else
layer uh and and you said representation
and input that into an MLP to make the
final prediction and that is all trained
end-to-end similar in the graph
classification case uh we are using gnns
to compute a node representation for all
the nodes in the graph we aggregate them
together in the permutation invariant
way and then apply a MLP on top to get a
prediction for a single graph
oh oh no uh sorry and in the link
prediction case
um we are now want to make a prediction
for a source node and a destination node
so the neural network gets us input the
graph and then the link We want to make
a prediction for in that case V and W
and for example we can then use an MLP
as well which is concatenate the
embeddings of the GNN to make a
prediction for given link we are
interested in
importantly and that is probably why
we're here implementing gnns is
ultimately challenging especially
because it does not really follow the
traditional deep learning toolbox we all
know
um one of these challenging challenges
is sparsity and irregularity which means
that all our graphs we want to process
are ultimately Dynamic and and may
change in size and neighborhood sizes
and so on and they're arise questions
such as like how can we effectively
paralyze this data and so on
um there's a underlying constraint of
heterogeneity in the underlying data so
we have input features that can be
numerical categorical that can be even
images and text and that may also be
different across different node types
and Edge types in our graph
and then as mentioned earlier graphs are
usually Dynamic and it's hard to find
scenarios in which graphs will not
change over time so you need to take
that into account and then there exists
various different requests on
scalability in the sense that some
graphs may be more spots than other
graphs sometimes we even work on highly
dense graphs or fully connected graphs
and so on and then there is this
tradition or this classic
contrast between operating on many many
small graphs which might happen if you
think about like a molecule data set
where each molecule has like 10 or 20
nodes but we're actually working on a
data set that contains like millions of
molecules versus operating on The Social
Network where we just have a single
giant graph but that single giant graph
May consist of millions of billions of
uses
um and then there's the applicability to
a set of diverse tasks in the sense that
our framework or how we Implement gnns
should not restrict to which task we
want to apply that GNN so we have node
level link level graph level test as
mentioned earlier but that also should
naturally support
tasks such as clustering pre-training
self-supervision and so on
and so our solution to that which is
fully open sourced uh is called paiji or
previously known as python geometric and
the goal here is that we have a python
based framework that bundles the
state-of-the-art in graph representation
learning by implementing various layers
architectures and examples known from
latest research
and so I'm especially proud of over 350
contributors now
and in particular the whole project has
kind of grown from like a single person
project to a project that is now
maintained by many many people and many
many different companies such as
different universities our own startup
Kumo AI as well as Nvidia and Intel
and so in in the essence paiji com
consists or contains four major
components one is that it contains graph
based neural network building blocks so
it contains message passing layers so
GNN layers known from latest research
graph based normalization layers pooling
layers readout layers and so on and they
are all defined on unified interfaces
such that it can easily be extended and
you can easily Implement your own on top
of that
then we are having a graph storage layer
and the graph storage layer helps us to
Define graph-based data sets and
graph-based data loaders so in
particular we have support for
homogeneous and heterogeneous graphs you
can have direct access to over 200
different Benchmark data sets and we
also support 10 or thousands of
different sampling techniques which I
will talk more about later
and then we have graph Transformations
and augmentations which are kind of
Applied before we load in the data into
our neural network architecture and
these augmentations are useful such as
like dropping nodes and edges during
your during your training routines which
amounts to some kind of Dropout but you
can also use that to transform your
graph so that it fits into the
um the needs of a GNN such as defining
meta paths on top and so on and
importantly that scheme also or this
concept of transformation also allows us
to not only support graphs but also
meshes and point clouds in the sense
that we can use K nearest neighbor
search on the point Cloud to construct a
graph on top of that and then use Pi G
to process that graph
and we are working hard on making paiji
the central place to practically learn
about gnns so we now provide video call
UPS blog posts and click application
driven graphml tutorials that let you
practically learn about gnns in the
first place
and so I quickly want to show the
general pipeline of how Pai G looks in
practice and the main goal here is that
we're trying to achieve is that paiji is
like super modular so
in general we want that each of these
different steps can be easily swapped
out so you can you should be able to
easily swap the GNN layer see the
performance you should immediately see
how in the impacts of graph
Transformations and so on so in the end
all it's it it always starts with the
data you want to operate on
and as I said earlier you have access to
predefined data sets but you can also
create your own data sets on top and
then in your python script you just
simply instantiate that graph and apply
the necessary transformations
and so the graph creation step in pi G
looks as follows so we always expect a
graph in either a COO or a CSR format
which is like a super popular spouse
Matrix format and that allows us to
model complex heterogeneous graphs so
for example we can instantiate a
heterogeneous data object and then just
write information to that object from
different node types and Edge types so
for example we can write node features
to a user and a product node type
and write that to the attribute X and
then we can also
um write Edge type information
using this this Tuple annotation here
where we want to specify information
from a user to a given product and here
we can Define The Edge index which is
basically the graph indices that
describes this connection we can add
edge information such as ADD features or
the time of these edges and so on
importantly
um
and what I want to highlight here is
that in academic graphs these data sets
are already curated and ready to be used
for us but if you want to apply your GNN
on your own industry graph then that
basically means you have to think about
how you
move your input graph to the expected
format of Pi G and so what you need to
respect is for example what is the best
graph design that I can pick from that
is suitable for this underlying message
passing scheme of gnns in the sense that
you want inform important information
close by to to Target nodes and then you
have to think about how can I put a
continuous features into my neural
network architecture so we're speaking
of feature selection feature encoding
and so on at the level of graphs
after that
you're basically free to Define any task
on on top of these data sets and we
usually use this y notation here to
specify like node labels and so on
um
and so again in academic graphs these
training labels and data splits are
predefined and ready to be used
um but in the industry setting you have
to again think about like how can I
build my own training labels and
importantly one of the data set splits I
want to use especially it has been shown
that random splits are like overly optim
optimistic and better scenarios might be
temporal splits and so on
next
um once you define your data set you
need to think about how you can obtain
mini batches from that
and Pai Chi provides over
10 different sampling techniques that
work by
sub sampling subgraphs and otherwise the
graph would not fit into GPU memory and
so the general procedure here is that
our graph is stored on CPU memory we
sample a subgraph move that subgraph to
the GPU and apply a neural network on
top
and afterwards you are free to Define
your own custom GNN layer and you have
different flavors to choose from you can
use predefined GNN models that are used
that are built using state-of-the-art
practices you can build your own GNN
layer with customized building blocks as
we've done as we are doing here in the
sense that we are using like a sagecon
flare which is a popular variant of a
GNN layer and then defining our
computation graph on top but you can
also go one step further and just Define
your own GNN layers and use that in your
custom GNN pipeline
and afterwards the training and
inference routines are like super
straightforward and similar to vanilla
pie torch in the sense that we just
iterate over the data you move it to the
GPU you apply the forward path
um you create the law or the compute the
loss on top of that and then use Bank
propagation and gradients as designed to
move the model parameters to the right
direction
and so poetry is not limited by any of
that so you can have full customization
from model architecture to training
routines
but I think it's important to note that
there are some Concepts where you need
deeper knowledge about gnns and in
particular it's important to note that
the best mobile architecture is usually
both data and task dependent so
um what is the best GNN for the given
task how can we capture long-range
information you might find scenarios
where you need to deal with class
imbalances over fitting and so on and
that is hard to answer it needs to be
studied on a case-by-case basis
so that is the general overview of
pipeline of of Pi G and I quickly want
to go a bit deeper on heterogeneous gnns
before I hand it off to Ramona and
heterogeneous gnns are known as graphs
where we have different node types and
Edge types and that is here a classic
example of a heterogeneous graph where
we have like paper nodes and these paper
nodes are connected by which paper has
cited which paper and then we have
author nodes which are described by
which author has written which paper and
then these different authors may also be
affiliated with some kind of ins
institution here and then you can think
about tasks such as what is the subject
area of a given paper
all right so the general message passing
scheme of a heterogeneous GNN looks
super similar to what I have presented
before but it has some small differences
in particular we are now only iterating
over the neighborhoods that are bound to
a specific Edge type so we first iterate
over the number of relations in our
graph
then apply a distinct GNN on top of that
for each Edge type we have in our graph
and then aggregate all these different
embeddings we get together to get a
final representation of a note
and so the general computation from a
homeless Gene homogeneous GNN to a
heterogeneous GNN May then look as
follows so on the left we have the
classic computation flow of a
homogeneous GNN which applies like
different GNN layers applies a
non-linearity between them and so on and
then finally reads out these node
embeddings but in a heterogeneous GNN it
would look like follows so we may have
two node types here the name denoted as
H1 and H2 and then we create distinct
GNN layers for each Edge type in our
graph and here in this in this setting
we would have three different Edge types
and then the computation is defined by
which Edge types aggregate information
from which source node to the
destination node
and so
since this looks similar but it's still
different we found a way in paiji to
automatically convert homogeneous gnns
to heterogeneous ones using the pi torch
torch.fx package if you don't know that
about that I heavily suggest you look
into that because it's pretty cool and
lets you do really crazy things and so
in the essence what what happens here is
that we create a homogeneous graph
attention Network here which is known as
gat
um
um and that just computes
um that is a two-layer GNN and that
computes like 72 output features and
then we call this two heater function
here which takes in the model the node
types and the edge types in our
heterogeneous graph and that gives you a
heterogeneous Gene and back that is
built on similar principles as the graph
attention Network and what that does
under the hood is that it duplicates the
GNN layers for each Edge types so that
we have this distinct model parameters
for each Edge type it then transformed
the underlying computation graph such
that messages are exchanged along
different Edge types as shown earlier
um and then we're using this concept of
lazy initialization here which is known
as this minus one in the input channels
um and that allows us to handle
different input feature dimensional
dimensionalities without specifying them
beforehand
and with that
um I'm happy to hand it over to Ramona
thanks do you have any questions before
we go into the Practical sessions do you
think you need anything
before
that
this is the QR code for the collab
notebook
for all of those
who want to uh
also play a little bit around with it
then just scan that and open it on your
computer
okay I don't see any phones anymore so I
guess you all have
copied it
yes
it doesn't open it doesn't work
[Music]
can you share it over the
anything like this
because for everyone is so unless
foreign
share it in three one time
I think we're A5
I can already start talking about the
task we are looking into
while you're copying the link
so we're looking into the movie lens
data set which is a data set containing
information about movies and users that
have rated the movies
and we're going to predict the rating a
user gives a specific movie
is there still anyone who doesn't
have the collab notebook open
okay
but you have the link right
so first uh The Notebook Works a bit
faster if we use a GPU so if you go to
edit and then go to notebook settings
then you will be able to choose whether
to use a GPU
or not so you can change that and then a
notebook the training will be faster
uh
and then first for installing python
geometric we first need to know which
torch version we have and like the first
cell gives you the option to check for
the version and then we see that the
notebook already has pre-installed
pytorch 2.0
and with this information uh
[Music]
pretty slow
might be
with this information we can specify the
python geometric uh
version we want to download so there are
two libraries we have the pi G lips with
pi G lip which is the the foundational
library and then we have Pi G
which we both want to install in The
Notebook and then additionally we have
like uh three other libraries which we
need for the pre-processing and for the
explainability but they're not uh
specific to Pi G
I think the installation also takes a
couple of seconds
so as I said uh like the goal of this
practical session is to learn how to
load a set of CSV files construct a
heterogeneous graph data object from it
and then learn a model on top of it for
in our case a link regression task so we
want to know how a user would rate a
movie that the user hasn't seen before
here
we saw kind of like uh how the graph
should look like so we have like movies
and then users and we have information
about uh which user rated a movie so
this is kind of the graph we want to
construct
and like the data set is
is publicly available it's like a toy
data set created from the group lens
research group and we can just like
specify a URL and then download the data
set
it will then pop up here
and we can read in we're especially
interested in in two different tables
which is the rating tables and the movie
tables and we can load them from the
vcsv file into a pandas data frame
and we will see that each movie
is assigned to different kind of genres
and we also have the title information
and the release year of each movie
additionally to the movies data frame
we also have a ratings data frame which
gives us information about the links
between users and movies so we see which
user rated which movie with how many
stars
so this is like the the base data set
and
I would kind of like uh to ask you to
add manual ratings so they're like two
different ways how we can add our own
ratings to that data set because then in
the end we also get a personalized
predictions
uh so if any of you have IMDB ratings
then it's very easy to export them and
upload them there is an instruction it's
like 30 seconds
is there anyone who has IMDB ratings in
an account
okay yeah if you like then you can do it
for the others
um
for the others there is
like we have in total 10 000 movies so
the most rated movies are for example
Forrest Gump or Jurassic Park
and you can specify how many you how
many movies you want to rate so let's
say we want to rate
for movies
and then you can enter whatever movie
you want to rate let's say Avatar
then it gives you the uh
whatever is in the movie data frame
which sounds similar as the title you
entered
if it's one of the titles you want to
rate
you can give the ID and your rating
and if you specify a couple of them
then you can in the end get a personal
recommendation and then also see
which of your ratings influenced the
predictions
I'm also going to
rate a couple of them
but yeah you can also I can also just
upload my
how's that work
okay
I think that doesn't work at the moment
but
yeah did anyone try to upload the IMDB
ratings
yeah
almost okay
um
thank you
in the end you need to add your ratings
to the ratings that were given in the
data set
still seeing some people adding movies
and ratings
okay
foreign
still wants to add more movies
more ratings
okay then I continue with the
pre-processing so we have now the pure
table of ratings including our own
ratings and then we also have the table
of movies we cannot like put this as it
is into a graph data object because we
have for example the title which is text
and cannot be processed by a neural
network so we need to pre-process this a
bit so we first have the genre
um column which we just uh one hot
encode so we receive a
20 dimensional vector and then in
addition we also use a pre-trained
sentence Transformer model for the
titles
this might take a couple of seconds
and it will download
the model and then transform
the titles we then concatenate the genre
and the title features to one movie
feature vector
or Matrix
we don't have in this data set any
information about users so we don't know
uh like their gender or age or anything
else so we will just use an identity
Matrix to
to for the neural network as input
features
then like those were like the the
features for the nodes
but then we also want to somehow store
in the data objects the connection
between those nodes and we do this with
the rating CSV where we have the links
between them and we will construct
something called an edge in DC
which contains the information of both
which user linked what
what movie
and it will be in the form of two times
the number of ratings
and what we do first is as in the table
we got we don't have consecutive numbers
so we have for example Movie 1 10 and
then 12 but there's no movie in between
and just to have it like more compact we
map uh both the user IDs and the rating
IDs to a consecutive range so we create
like a data frame containing the
original user ID and the map user ID
which is consecutive
same for the for the movie
and after creating this
we use the map user ID and stack them
together and receive a tensor which
looks like this
and contains all the edge or link
information so user 0
rated movie Zero and so on
we now are ready to construct the data
object so as mati has already showed in
his slides this data object would look
like we have a heterogeneous data object
and we would now pass the user features
to
to the user attribute in the data object
same with the movie features and then we
also add the edges
to the object
additionally in this case as like
the target is the rating we add edge
label so what Matia showed was in the
table was using and why on on a note but
in this case we are not predicting uh
node type or node classification we
don't have a node classification task
and that's why we use an edge label
we also use one of the transformation
function which means we transform the
directed graph so at the moment we only
have connections from users to movies
but we want also that the GNN is able to
pass messages in the other direction so
that we can also learn something from
movies to users
so we undirect the graph which then also
undirects the edge label but we don't
want to have the edge labels in the
other direction so we delete them again
and with this we
we create a heater data object which
looks like the following so we have 9000
movies and we have a hundred thousand
edges between them and also labels on
every Edge which represents the rating
and then we also have the reverse edges
but no labels for it
we
are ready for training a model
but then before we need to split the
edges into a training validation and
test set
um
so we specify that we have 10 of the
edges part of the validation set 10 of
the test set and we split it randomly
here we see that we have 8
000 edges being part of the train data
so the First Data you see is the train
data and the second one is the validator
so you get back with this random link
split function uh you get back at two
new data objects and what is also new
here now is that we have the edge label
index and this one is required for
telling the model on which edges we need
to make predictions so in the training
uh in the training data we make
prediction on all edges but in for
example in the test
and validation data set we have
10 000 Edge label indices but 8 000 Edge
labels meaning we take the edge labels
from the training set use them as the
basis and then predict on Ten Thousand
new edges that we add
similar is Matthias described in the
presentation
we can construct the model quite easily
we have here a specific way of
constructing the model as we have link
prediction or link regression task
so we first learn an encoder which
learns an embedding for the user and for
the movie
and then after
passing the graph through the encoder we
apply a decoder which combines the
embedding of a user and a movie and then
gives the rating based on the two
embeddings
uh
the GNN encoder
is I think basically the same as the one
we showed on the slides so it's a
homogeneous graph
and with two graph layers graph
convolutional layers
and then when we initialize the
the model we can just transform it to a
heterogeneous
model
and the decoder is then as I said it
combines so you give in the edge label
indices which tells you uh which links
you want to get a prediction for
and then you combine the user embedding
and the movie embedding
and apply
a normal linear layers on top of an it
to get a final rating prediction
this is let's say
standard to use or
because I have the feeling that a lot of
what is happening here depends on this
particular function so uh through here
exists for now over one and a half years
uh it's pretty stable
um but there are some Corner cases where
it might fail if you lose like a super
specific GNN architecture but
importantly you don't have to use that
so you can easily convert like a g and N
layer to a heterogene layer and then
build your your pipeline
um
in the in a more like fine-grained way I
would say
um but I felt this this true heater
conversion makes it like super
straightforward to to build like like
most of the the classic gnns and just uh
a useful uh helper function
so here we see how the model then looked
uh
so we have as Matias also said we have a
different
convolutional layer for each Edge type
and then in the end
we have the linear layers
which predicts the rating based on the
combined embeddings of the user and the
movie
and the training of the of the GNN is
like very similar to any other pie torch
model
we first uh put both the model and the
data on the desired device and we
initialize an optimizer
where we specify some some
learning rates
and then we have like a training Loop
which just applies the
the data to the model
and then so here we see the
one one training Loop
so we pass a Tudor model
One X dict which is like just all the
features
for every every node type as a
dictionary and then we have the same for
the edge indices
so this way you can access what we
specified earlier in a dictionary
so here we specified it as an attribute
of
of the data user and here we get it as a
dictionary
and then additionally we also passed the
labels we want to get ratings for
then we get predictions out of the model
and we combine that or compare it to our
actual ratings and compute the loss from
it and then update the model parameters
based on that loss
it should go pretty quickly
so we see that we have like a training
uh
Arrow of 0.8 and a validation error of
zero point
eight nine or 0.85 for training which
kind of means that like the prediction
of the rating is 0.9 off from the actual
rating
this is kind of due to that the data set
is very small
and we could we also haven't like
uh find huge the model a lot so that's a
very basic model
and we can just apply the same to a test
to the test data
and kind of see here of visualized for
which user which movie what we predicted
as a rating and what the actual Target
was
here
it's just because otherwise the data
frame doesn't
it's just for visualization
so now coming back to our own ratings we
gave
as we have now trained the model
uh we can just
um
like this cell implements that you get a
random movie which for example here is
for me the reader and then you can in
the next cell gets how many Ray how many
stars you would give to this movie even
if you haven't seen it so it would just
generate generate a random movie that
you haven't seen
and in the next cell
we will see that the model thinks that I
would give 4.3 Stars
to this
movie
yeah I should probably watch that
final last step uh
since a couple of months paiji also
supports explanations or we had like a
GNN explainers before but now we have a
general framework for explainers
so we can also look into what influenced
the predictions and use different kind
of algorithms
now I kind of like want to know why and
what influenced the decision that I
would like the movie The Reader and
would rate it that high
and what I can do in pi G then is use
the explainer
class I would like pass that explainer
class my model
and then also I would select the
algorithm
capital is also just like an open source
library for explainability or
interpretability and we built a wrapper
around
Captain such that Captain can also be
used with gnns and Captain has a list of
different attribution methods including
integrated gradients
so we can just specify that here and use
that integrated gradient attribution
method from Captain
we also specify that we want to use we
want to get an explanation for the model
output what you can also do in case of a
of a classification you can even if the
model put output is that it would
predict class 3 you can still ask for an
explanation why it didn't predict class
one
and then you would give uh here
not the model but the class you want to
pre if you want to get the explanation
for we also specify some some
information about our model such that
it's a regression model
and we the task level is The Edge and
the return type of the of the model is
the Raw
uh output
there are different kind of explanation
we can get we can get information on for
example node features so how important
was the title of the movie for the
prediction how important was the title
of the movie that is like two hops away
that someone someone else as a user has
rated
and we can get information on the
importances of edges
and here I'm only going to look into the
into the edges
and
we can just call the explainer with the
data we have
and the edge label and the edge label
here in this case only contains uh the
the
NDC from
my user and the the the movie The Reader
so you get like one explanation for this
specific link prediction
uh
case
it outputs
uh heater explanation object
which contains again the user and the
movie information and also the original
Edge index information but then
additionally we also have something
called Edge mask which contains the
information of how much each of the edge
contributed to the final prediction
we I mean as there are many edges like
90 thousands we don't want to look into
all of them
uh so what the next cell does
is
first
um
what do we do here
so we output we just concatenate both
Edge masks to one data frame and we see
kind of that the user 231 rated the
movie
3445 and then we see the attribution of
this link so it's in this case negative
and means that the case that this user
rated this movie kind of like shifted
away at the
the prediction meaning that if there
wouldn't be this link then the
prediction would be higher so then we
would for example get 4.2 or 4.3 as a
prediction instead of 4.1
um
to make it a bit more clear we only look
into the into the movies we rate it so I
want to know how much did the two movies
are I rated I rated the Schindler's List
and Avatar how much did they contribute
to the final predictions and we see that
the fact that I rated Schindler's List
contributed more than the fact that I
rated the Avatar movie
that's it that was the Practical part
I can take now of some questions if you
have questions on the notebook otherwise
we have some a couple of slides left and
then we can go later for the Q and a
session
can be a neural network
maybe the person can clarify the
question
from the internet
maybe a different question
another example for graphs or
so
what else we could imagine as a graph or
hmm
I mean kind of like a typical business
graph could be that you just have users
and products and that would be already a
heterogeneous graph if you have
information about whether a user bought
a specific product
that is I would say kind of a typical
business application
do you have one I mean
the traffic network will would look like
a way you have a Crossroads death notes
for example and then like these edges
would denote uh like roads and then you
would have Edge features where how long
it would usually takes to travel a
certain route and so on
um and then you can use that for example
for navigation and so on and that is
actually what deepmind is doing as well
as far as I remember there was some
some highlights in last year or
something like that where I would keep
in mind uh like revolutionized traffic
prediction using gnns
yes
accelerated like a graph core ipu
oh that's that's funny because we just
came back from a London event where we
like uh announced our collaboration with
craft core ipus and graphql published a
bunch of notebooks on their end and they
have some some paper space notebook
experience where you get like six hours
a day for free to use graphql ipus with
pi G
great
I want to continue
um okay so I'll quickly wrap this
session up
um and so what you have seen here is uh
how the different problems of gnns how
they are defined and how you can
practically use them and I see
personally Pi G as a low level Library
like an engine where you can like fully
customize everything but that usually
also comes with certain disadvantages so
for example I often get complaints about
that one needs GNN expertise to use that
for example you're still responsible for
future engineering products and coding
pods how you actually Define your graph
and so on and so if you're not fully
into gnns it might be a steep learning
curve and we're trying to bridge that
Gap by providing many many tutorials and
so on but in the end
um
if you really want to productionize it
as well there's an additional layer of
complexity that comes into play for
example currently Pai G only supports
like CPU based graph storages and you
would have to think about how you can
connect to a graph database and so on
and if you want to write like baby daily
batch predictions and so on you may want
to manage the life cycle of your graph
so that you update your graph regularly
on a on a scheduled basis and then there
are some additional questions like
production orchestration and so on and
so what we're also trying to do is that
we're trying to build a framework on top
of Pi G which we named kumu that
automatically tries to overcome all
these problems at once and so the goal
here of this new framework is that you
don't need to really dig deep into gns
and just use them if you want to and so
what that looks like in practice would
be that you can connect your raw data
using one click and so you could connect
to S3 data warehouses and so on and
they're built from the premise that all
your data is kind of stored in a
relational database and so what kumu
then does is that you connect your
tables uh into into the kumu framework
and then you specify how these different
tables are connected for example using
primary Keys foreign keys and so on and
then we're building this graph from
scratch for you in the sense that we
connect Frankie's primary keys so that
gives us direct linkage but we're also
doing some more advanced option here
such as bringing tables that are far
away in the graph nearer to the to the
to the table you want to make a
prediction for
and then we think about how we can make
um
formalizing the task as easy as possible
and we're coming up with a declarative
language here which we call predictive
query where you can just say for which
for which entity you want to make a
prediction for for which time frame and
based on what Target and in that case
here for example is a symbol query
language would look like that we are
interested in the average amount of of
the balance between now and the next 90
days for each user account
um and that's a product where a
framework we're currently building that
uses Pi G as the engine
um but gives you like more high level
interface to get familiar with gnns and
with that I'm happy to conclude this
session here and we're both happy to
answer any questions if there are any
[Applause]
yes
um
but could you give like a couple of
examples but like compared to deploying
like a deep neurology like what what
would be like
another challenge
so I would say the the two most
challenge or the two most problematic
challenges is scalability and updating
your graph so uh usually if we think
about large-scale graphs we speak about
15 billions of edgers for example and
then you can no longer store that in a
CPU you need like a distributed learning
scenario and so on so that is one
Challenge and then the other challenge
is to constantly update this graph over
time because graphs are usually changing
and you always if you want to make a
prediction you always want to intercorp
incorporate the latest information into
you into your GNN
um and I would say these are the two two
biggest problems that you overcome
yes
somehow on the graph like when you go
like a link should never exist
always exists so it's like
to do
you don't want
come to learn that part but still want
to be somehow able to feed in the graph
completely
or do you have to do this like more like
afterwards like that you would like to
post-processing step or
or maybe a three parents that oh okay
I'm you want to take that or um okay I'm
not fully sure I understood that
question but give me I may be able to
give you an example so there's one line
of research which is called like signed
graph neural networks where you can
specify like is it a positive Edge is
that a negative Edge and then you could
specify these rules as part of your
input graph and then the G and N should
be able to learn and generalize that
rule across the prediction does it
answer your question to some extent
be a good way
back
into this
like sort of products and you just know
that certain products combinations are
not possible like if
certified product X and Y then you just
know that it can
all products that
that you can somehow
50. okay okay so there are two two
adjustments here you would need to make
so if you train that model that would be
you're responsible for defining the
negative sampling strategy and if you're
sure that like you're never sample a
certain set of nodes then there's no
point to include that in your negative
symbols and then in the batch prediction
phase where you really want to predict
gnns you wouldn't
want or you wouldn't need to predict on
the set of nodes that are like not
included in in this in the set that you
want to make a prediction for
like if you want to for example
recommend the store for a given user
then it makes no point in recommending a
store that is like in the USA right now
um and so you would never just input
that into the GNN
um so technically if you train it that
way it would give you probably a low
score for these stores as well but you
would still need to compute that right
so if you know about that in advance you
should include that in your
pre-processing pipeline
you're still not looking super happy but
possibility
okay happy to follow up with that
uh yeah the man in the green shirt
um
and my question is
[Music]
no question
um
I you have been talking about a lot how
you know we know that graphs always
change so that's kind of a fact and but
there are also specific libraries that I
think also build on top of these that
include like this temporal Dimension
explicitly
so uh my question would be like what's
your perspective on
including this type of information
exclusive
ly in the graph or not and I mean
it makes sense to also include something
like that into five
um yes so that's a very good question
um so there exists indeed like extension
libraries built on top of Pi G and one
of them is known as pyrogeometric
temporal sadly uh I think it got really
successful but it doesn't look really
maintained right now so we're trying to
move
some of this to Pi G native directly and
I don't want to spoil too much and I'm
not even sure if I'm allowed to talk
about that but I don't think we are on
the internet as well but anyway
um
so what we're building in combination
with pi G is like a temporal open graph
data set
um that really drives or tries to derive
the efforts of building more temporal
gnns from the community and index in
combination with that we're fully trying
to support more temporal graph GNN
models into Pi G as well and that is
yeah it's not ready yet but we're we're
thinking about that and we're making
great progress for that
but just to finalize there exists
already some GNN models in Pai G that
can make use of temporal gnns and we
also support like
um Advanced data processing such as
temporal sampling and so on so that is
all ready to use
um but I wouldn't say it's like 100 done
probably it's never done but we're
working towards that
yes
um
regarding
so right now it looks to be built around
my torch
how easy would it be to swap the
computational backend for something else
to be able to say okay I have a tensor
for my
parameters for the edges
Forge model in the end but but model
built with let's say tensorflow or
objects or whatever
yeah how hard would it be to critical
question okay
um first of all
we have been moving away from our own
external libraries and so we're mostly
fully relying now on Native pie torch
which helps us tremendously in the way
we can export Pi G models so we can use
like onnx we can use torch script to to
export our models and that is all fully
supported
um from the
perspective of supporting different deep
learning libraries I would say
pythosh is so coupled with paiji that
it's like super hard to move away from
there
and so we're really relying on the
success of Fighters here I know
um
the one thing I would say is that it
gives us many advantages to just rely on
a single deep learning library because
we can use like new features introduced
that directly into Pai G and so we're
also working closely with the pytorch
team and in in as a result of that like
they heavily improved this boss Matrix
support and so on and that is something
we cannot really get if we just if we're
relying on multiple back-ends so then we
are just limited by the union of
features of all these different
libraries and I think that's like an
important consideration to make and
probably wouldn't change that direction
if I would start from scratch and
um and so yeah we're relying on
exporting models if you want to use like
tensorflow also on
yes
yes okay very very good question
um so we had a workshop last September
where we announced like Pi G 2.2 and
that relief comes with a clear interface
uh on to connect to different graph
backends and so what we do is we provide
interfaces for a feature store and a
graph store and that basically
um
basically allows us for independent
scale out independent of CPU memory and
so if you implement that interface of
graph story and feature store for
example for a neo4j then that would mean
that we can directly sample the
subgraphs and Sample features from that
graph database and that would produce
those Pi G mini batches and so what we
do right now is we're working with
several graphs database
providers such as tiger graph or kuzu
and they have been both able to
implement that interface and I'm not
sure I previously I talked to someone
from neo4j but we have that on the
roadmap as well
yes
thank you so much
um I do have a question regarding the
scalability so your face you've already
mentioned uh the whole set of broadly
less discountable due to the
utorridge
is it is it like
thinkable of uh using the graph neural
network setup with all the
across them across the task
um kind of
um
tasks let's put it like that being
multi-target prediction or having your
measure the node metadata no description
uh been pictures or any sort of other
different non-tabular inputs
to to combine those approaches and say
in order to predict not only
um the the
or the
what was that their IMDb score but let's
let's also predict a second second
dimension of Target the
are needed
for instance or just or also like
putting a teaser into an input like a
sharp frame
um
already something that one could
possibly or is it in in development
so
that is like fully supported it just
needs to be written by you and so what
that means is like you have full control
full customizability of the training
Loop like if you want to predict like a
military Target then you just output two
predictions instead of one and train
that together right so that is super
super straightforward regarding your
question about input features that is a
tricky one because you always need to
encode your features right and you can
either then like if you if you want to
include like image covers of all the
movies for example you can either like
use a pre-trained resnet compute the
embedding detach the embedding from the
computation graph and just use them as
an input features or you could jointly
train your CNN and GNN together
um
the problem with that is that this
likely yields your GPU memory error
because what we see for example in this
demo is that we are operating on like
1K or 10K movies for a single prediction
and that would also mean that your batch
size in your CNN would be around the
same right
with unlimited GPU
yes with unlimited GPU all all of that
supported
yes
um so I try to do to display the data
differently
um
presentation
is because for many is because my
problem
or is just something natural
so I'm just following
um okay uh not fully sure I can help you
with that just on a high level
thought but
I've
so the problem is that if you have a
graph data set and you split that your
graph data set looks different
afterwards
every time you run the split and that is
with a fixed seat so the number
and that is a note level 10 score graph
level task
okay that should be the case so
um maybe I don't know maybe uh the seat
isn't isn't respected by some some
random operator or something like that
uh otherwise I'm I'm not sure happy
happy to help you out on on slack or
GitHub with that problem I think it's
solvable
yes
I have also a question but maybe more
regarding humor because more from a
you know
product engineer
perspective like we had an example about
these movies
and we had a individual inputs from
everyone and we had individual results
but let's say we want to have a movie
night and people rate movies differently
but we don't want to end up with a
trailer night so we just want to decide
which movie to watch like a collective
decision
can we make this with
work as well interesting question
um so like the first thought that comes
to my mind is that you're just
predicting the top K movies for each
user and then try to learn like to how
to combine them right but if you think
about something more fancy I would say
you can
add these clusterings as part of your
training pipeline so in the sense that
you have some kind of hierarchical graph
so like a user rates a given movie and
then you have like a cluster of users
that rate a given movie as part of group
or something like that
that would be something that would be
doable but I'm not sure if it's really
practical to do that
um
yes so that would be related to to like
a hyper Edge CNN yes
so
the way you would treat that is that you
somehow learn how to aggregate the
information from each user
into some kind of of the cluster
decision exactly and ideally you want to
train that as well
might work might not but
uh that's something we we haven't we
haven't looked into it to be honest um
so um
if you define the Clusters as part of
your your graph then then we can do it
yes
no more questions than thank you very
much for your very interesting thanks
for attending
foreign
[Applause]